prison
and if for some reason you are
unfamiliar with the concept i'll let a
beloved children's entertainer explain
it to you in a clip that has in no way
dated badly
all of those people who are in prison
right now
were kids once just like you and then
somewhere along the way they did
something wrong
something dumb whatever it was it
probably started
small became bigger maybe they even got
away with it at first and thought
they'd never get caught they were wrong
now they're in prison yes
they are it's almost like they
should have really seen this coming and
look on this show we've talked before
about the problems of mass incarceration
but this story isn't so much about
who is in prison or whether they should
be there it's about what they are doing
while they are inside which is to say
that broadly it's a story about prison
labor
because over 60 percent of people in
prison actually have jobs in fact
prisons are basically operated by the
inmates as you would know
if you've ever seen an episode of lock
up raw on msnbc
the most common jobs are working in the
kitchen or some form
of janitorial duty i you know clean
carpet vacuum empty trash i work in
laundry here five days a week
monday through friday he has recently
landed one of the most coveted inmate
jobs
staff canteen clerk i didn't come into
prison with a staff canteen job i
started in
food service in the dish room and worked
my way right on through the ranks
oprah didn't start on oprah winfrey show
so i mean he is right of course oprah
didn't start on the oprah winfrey show
oprah started when a glowing magical orb
consolidated all of the earth's energy
into one mesmerizing
perfect beacon of light then the light
the orb
and the result was oprah that's oprah's
origin story right there
but there are some major differences
between the jobs people do
in prison and the ones they do on the
outside particularly when it comes to
money
the average wage in prisons is around 63
cents per hour and remember
that's the average so that means there
are states where prisoners make
considerably less
in texas georgia arkansas and alabama
prisoners are not paid for their work at
all and in some places
they're required to work under threat of
disciplinary action
if they say no i'm not going to work
they can write you up for that they can
send you to solitary for that that's
that's
that's slavery to
work for free yeah and then they can and
they can put you in solitary if you
don't
work or write you up for not working
yeah for free
why is that not slavery yeah that's not
good because
why is that not slavery it's one of
those questions that even if you have to
ask it something has already gone very
wrong
like how many swastika tattoos or
which of mommy's nightstand draws did
you open things are already bad
we just need to figure out how bad
and the answer to why is this not
slavery is well it's
not exactly not slavery because it turns
out treating prisoners as slaves is
literally written into the constitution
the 13th amendment states that slavery
is abolished except
as a punishment for a crime and the
amendment abolishing slavery
is really not the one that you want to
suddenly include the word accept
and look i know that to many inmates are
not a naturally sympathetic group of
people
in fact when there was a push to get a
higher wage for those working behind
bars a few years ago
these people on fox found it hilarious
inmates behind bars are now suing for
the minimum wage for the work they're
doing behind bars
should that be a crime he says he
deserves
minimum wage as if crime pays
why let crime pay exactly crime should
not pay it's very simple
common sense is very simple this is
common sense
it's very simple look first of all if
you watch that on mute you would
definitely assume it was a panel on
erectile dysfunction and
even with the sound on you you can't
definitely say it's not but
but in a way in a way i actually get it
crime doesn't pay
does sound like common sense but it's
much much more complicated than that
the truth is when you combine the low to
non-existent wages
that prisoners get paid with these
surprisingly high costs that they and
their families can incur while they're
inside
the current system can wind up costing
all of us and tonight
we're going to look into how how
prisoners make and spend money
and the companies that have managed to
get rich off them and let's start with
the fact that prison labor can take many
forms it is often the janitorial or
kitchen work that you saw earlier but in
some states
prisoners actually work as firefighters
in fact in the california wildfires last
year
around 12 of the firefighters were
current inmates
and i should say many of them find
fighting fires very rewarding
just the other day we were able to save
houses from from burning down to have
a woman come out to her backyard and
thank
us for saving her house makes us
feel like we're doing something now
being able to give back
and potentially save lives
is um it's huge
yeah and that makes sense being able to
save lives must be very satisfying it's
why batman always seems to be in such a
good mood
and what his catchphrase is we i'm
batman how great is fact in crime it's
great i love it
and and that honestly feels like the
best case scenario for prison labor
people who are happy to work
contributing to society and learning new
skills although it is worth noting
those firefighters base pay is only
between three and five dollars per day
for that dangerous work and if you're
thinking well at least they're learning
skills
that will help them get a job on the
outside that is often not the case
california law bars most people with a
criminal record
from becoming licensed emergency
responders which means that being a
firefighter in prison
is not unlike being an art history major
in college it may be fun while you're in
there
but you're not going to be doing it once
you get out do you hear that thessaly
you're going to work in human resources
you're gonna have a favorite coffee mug
and a throw pillow that says it's one
o'clock somewhere and you're gonna stare
out the window
yearning for the sweet release of death
just like
everybody else
and incidentally fighting fires
is far from the only dangerous job that
prisoners do at louisiana state
penitentiary
some take part in a prison rodeo where
the entertainment can be
insane take convict poker
four inmates sit nervously at a card
table
while a very restless bull picks out his
target
the last one standing or sitting
wins so why do you do this
money yeah i'm broke i'm trying to get a
private investigator on my keys
he earns two cents an hour working in
the prison fields
but he can earn hundreds out in that
month
[Applause]
holy that is truly shocking
also and look this really isn't the
biggest issue there but if you are going
to have a game where a bull attacks a
group of people
you don't name it convict poker you name
it dodgeball again
not not the biggest issue not the
biggest issue but i
i did want to bring it up and look
being attacked by a bull for
entertainment is clearly an outlier most
prisoners are doing routine labor for
little to no money the problem is
that can lead to them being seen less as
humans paying their debt to society
and more as a pool of virtually free
labor and don't don't take that from me
listen to louisiana sheriff steve prater
when the state
as part of a prison reform program
started releasing some inmates he went
public with an
unusual complaint in addition to the bad
ones
and i call these bad in addition to them
they're releasing some
good ones that we use every day to
to wash cars to change oil in our cars
to cook in the kitchens
to do all that where we save money well
they're going to let them out
the ones that we use in our work release
program they're going to let them out
just think about what he's saying there
he's saying
some people need to stay behind bars
because they're too valuable as a source
of free labor
which is exactly the same plan as the
villain in the shawshank redemption
normally to qualify as a stephen king
villain you have to be something way
less stupid like
an evil car or a guy who forgot to wear
a coat
and look many prisoners do prefer having
jobs
to just sitting in their cells all day
which again makes sense so
getting rid of prison labor entirely is
not
the answer here paying prisoners more
might help although that will be very
difficult
prisons are now so reliant on their
labor moving to a competitive wage could
cost
hundreds of millions of dollars each
year and i know that there are those out
there who might say well what do
prisoners
even need money for but the answer to
that question is actually
really important here because while it
may seem like you're living for free in
prison
you may actually have a lot of expenses
like legal fees
or basic necessities like soap or
shampoo and as lawmakers in arizona
recently discovered
prisons there were actually requiring
women to buy personal hygiene products
there's a new bill in the legislature
that would have the state pay for all
feminine hygiene products and first to
hear the proposal a committee of nine
men
some of them a bit squeamish about
taking on the task i guess hearing the
bill was something
i didn't expect i didn't expect
to hear pads and tampons and
and the problems of periods
okay so two things there first the
problem of period sounds like the title
of a medical textbook written back in
the time when we used to treat female
emotions with either electrocution or
drowning
and second i am frankly shocked that a
man who willingly chose that haircut
isn't more of an expert on women
but but the fact is until last year
arizona's female prisoners were allotted
just 12 pads per month which as
i am going to say at least half of you
know often
isn't nearly enough and extra hygiene
products were not a minor expense base
pay for prisoners starts at 15 cents an
hour
which meant that to buy one additional
pack of pads took about
21 hours of work and in theory women who
needed more could simply
ask prison guards or get a medical
dispensation but the problem is in
arizona as in many places
prisoners also have to pay a co-pay to
see a doctor
and i'll let a former prisoner
addressing that panel tell you how that
worked out in reality
the most important thing if i want to
request the medical right to get more
pads because say i have a heavier flow
this month than last month i would have
to pay four dollars
just to be seen by medical now when i'm
making ninth cents
uh after tax you got to really think if
i want to put my whole month's income
into
hopefully being allowed approved for
extra pads if they believe i deserve it
look not only is it utterly ridiculous
that she needs to pay
to make a case that she deserves access
to pads
just spare a thought for her having to
discuss the details of a heavy flow
into this bewildered face so it's pretty
clear that for many prisoners there is
an enormous gap between what they make
at their prison job and having enough
for basic necessities now
if they are lucky they might have family
or others on the outside willing to help
them out
by sending them money but even that is
more complicated than it appears and
this
brings us to the final absurd element
here the for-profit companies who stand
between
prisoners and the outside world because
let's say that you want to send money to
your incarcerated
son or daughter one of the biggest
companies that lets families do that is
jay pay but there is a catch in lots of
states
families have to go through jp to send
money into a prison at all for almost
450 000
families jp is the only way to send an
inmate money
and the company charges them fees as
high as 45
to give him 50 i have to i have to send
70 off of my card
it's hardest on people like pat taylor
who are barely scraping by
i just let a bill go i let a bill go and
pick it up later
it's true it costs her 20 just to send
50. so you know what that means
look out ticketmaster when it comes to
dickish transaction fees there's a new
in town
and charging families to transfer money
isn't the only way companies can profit
jpeg's parent company
securus is also a leader in the field of
charging prisoners for phone calls
and video visits which is a 1.2 billion
dollar a year
industry sakuras has ads which play like
a shitty apple commercial but
make it look like it's a warm fuzzy
company focused on human connections and
it's honestly nice that they are fully
acknowledging how important it is
for people to connect to others on the
phone it's frankly a lesson that at t
would do well to take
boom you suck at business daddy
business baby i never get in line this
baby rides dirty
wow where i'm fussy don't rub my tummy i
won't be settled
where but
what that ad doesn't make clear is just
how expensive they have successfully
made those vital connections
phone calls within states can go over a
dollar per minute and facilities served
by securist have had fees
over three dollars for the first minute
and 16 cents
for each additional one and that can
really add up which can be a massive
problem
for prisoners families who may have
limited resources
shaina palace is married to a man who is
currently facing a seven and a half year
sentence in prison palace has been
paying high telephone fees
trying to keep her daughter connected to
her father however she can
we're done though but at six dollars a
call
keeping that connection isn't easy you
know some people might not see six
dollars a day is a lot but
when you have an infant you know six
dollars a day is half of
you know a pack of diapers and that is
rough you should not have to choose
between letting your kid talk to her dad
and buying them diapers
that is pretty much the definition of a
shitty shitty situation
and if you curtail or remove that
connection it can have serious
consequences on life inside the prison
as those who have been there can tell
you
all a lot of guys have when they're
incarcerated are
those phone calls those letters those
visits
that's it that's what they live for
that's how they get through their time
i've seen guys
that family didn't come see him in a
week or two and the next thing you know
they ended up in a hole for 90 days
because they just felt alone because you
feel alone
you can't build a family in prison he's
right contact with families is
incredibly important and completely
unrelated
in the hole for 90 days is also how
sting describes a quickie
and and if you're thinking well hold up
maybe families can just get around phone
charges by
visiting their loved ones in person they
can although that is changing too
prisons and especially jails have been
phasing out in-person visits
in favor of video visitation meaning
that you can turn up to see a loved one
and still have to sit in a different
room and talk to them on a screen
incredibly this is something securist
has contractually mandated
up until 2015 some of their contracts
with facilities had them promised to
eliminate
all face-to-face visitation and that is
just evil machine that makes money by
stopping people from seeing their
families
sounds like an item at the top of
satan's amazon wishlist
right before superbed bugs cauliflower
rice and just the actual existence of
amazon
and while this sounds inhumane the
people running these facilities will
insist that the reason for it is purely
a safety
issue if you limit the people who are
coming in
uh you're going to limit the the
attempts of contraband you don't have to
worry about contraband if you're doing a
video visit you're not going to be able
to introduce contraband
into the jail okay i get it so it's a
contraband issue the problem with that
explanation is that research shows that
installing video visitation does not
decrease contraband
probably because it's easier for it to
come in through other ways like through
guards staff and occasionally through
owls although admittedly
that is mostly an azkaban problem so
so why push video visitation so hard it
is
difficult to say i will point out it
seems notable that jails and prisons
often get a cut of the proceeds
from phone and video calls and while
they will point out that the money goes
to an inmate welfare fund
that fund is often used for things other
than inmate welfare
one county spent nearly three quarters
of that money on staff salaries
while another dipped into it to buy
tasers tasers
which really stretches the definition of
inmate welfare
to a literally shocking degree and when
you put
all of this together you wind up with a
scenario where you're not just hurting
the people who are incarcerated
you're hurting everyone around them one
in three families of inmates reported
going into debt to pay for phone calls
or visitation which is
terrible and that doesn't really set up
a prisoner for success
once they are released look the current
system of low wages and high cost is
clearly no good for anyone
but for the companies who are somehow
managing to massively profit from this
and there are things that we can do here
small and large new york city
recently made phone calls from jails
free and connecticut will consider
similar legislation next year and if we
want to make bigger changes like paying
prisoners more
we could do that although as i've said
it would undeniably
be incredibly expensive and very
unpopular
you saw people argue crime doesn't pay
that's just common sense
but part of the way mass incarceration
persists in this country is by
keeping the true costs of it off the
books and we're currently doing that
through a combination of underpaid labor
from prisoners themselves
financially draining families who've
done absolutely nothing wrong
and occasionally managing to monetize
prisoners being launched into the
air with livestock
and at that point i would argue we've
come a long long way
from common sense